minecraft the game which took over the
world and i
completely missed it but now 11 years
later
i'm playing minecraft survival mode and
i'm officially the worst player to
ever step foot in minecraft if you're
new around these parts this is the
series inspired by luke the notable and
his 100 days series
the thing is i don't have a clue how to
play minecraft
and the rule here is quite simple i
cannot ask for help or use the internet
in any way
everything i learn is through playing
the game alone
all alone i recommend watching part one
before you see my struggles this time
around
so if you're ready let's noob this
[Music]
day 101 i haven't played minecraft in a
few months
and the first day was spent looking
around my home base i quickly remembered
how to farm again before
clearing a little space around the area
then i saw an enderman snooping around
and remembered i was never really safe
here
so to end my first day i completed my
golden armor
i like golden armor i can already feel
you judging me and it's only day one
the next day i wanted to get to work
again and my plan was to bring my
villagers from their home miles away
all the way back to this hobbit hole i
decided to use the train track we set up
in the last episode
i simply bumped them into the mine cart
and sent them on their way
it was surprisingly easy to be honest
but it took a long time
when the first guy arrived i
accidentally hit him and he ran away
and um never came back rip
update only a few minutes later i found
out that the minecarts didn't always get
the lads to the man cave
and found myself in a villager sandwich
long story short i got most of the gang
there and gave them a barracks to live
in
things were coming together our family
was growing
day 104 i returned home to see this
thing in my bedroom i left him alone and
decided that bed
was no longer my own day 105 was a
mining day i wanted this mountain
gone but i gave up i got bored i
ventured out into the night and quickly
remembered
going out at night just isn't worth it
the following morning i found the
runaway villager and tried to woo him
back home
before i knew it though those grey
marauders returned for another battle
oh no a raid started if my first 100
days taught me anything
it's not good to get involved in these
things and just come back in a few days
on day 107 my llamas returned luke and
leia
i decided to bring them indoors this
time to make sure they didn't run away
or despawn again i also try to use a
name tag
it does nothing right now i'm sure i'll
figure that out soon enough
the next morning i woke up to find this
guy watching me sleep
which is strange because it's usually me
watching your mum sleep
wow that's incriminating i was so sick
of the raid bar on screen
so i decided to take out the last
remaining marauder
that was a bad choice there's my first
death of the episode
it's gonna take a long long time before
i can try hardcore mode
on the evening of day 109 my world was
shattered
my family of villagers who moved in with
me have been murdered
i found this pig warrior dude in their
room it looks like keeping a portal in
the same room as guests
is not advisable full of vengeance i
broke the iron giant free
and let him take revenge for our peace
our nod was the sign of our shared
anguish
it's already day 110. i was thinking
about how that pig man came through the
portal and i thought it must be safe to
travel
the other way just in case there's lava
there i decided to take a bucket of
water
my master plan was to throw it down the
second i got there
here's how that plan went i really suck
at survival
day 111 i made a conscious choice to be
more productive with my time and began a
new build
i'm a total novice at building but i am
proud of that hut watch on the hill
and wondered if i could make a castle at
this point i still didn't understand the
materials i could use and always used
way too much cobblestone but i'm having
fun on day 113 i changed my idea from a
castle to a pagoda which is like a
japanese house thing if you don't know
what that is
stick with me for a few more minutes and
i'll show you as the sun sets
the base was in place the next day
brought rain
it made me realize how gray and boring
my pagoda will be
so i hatched a plan i needed wool i made
a fenced off area to keep my sheep from
running away
and slowly tempted a sheep over it took
a long time but eventually
i brought together two sheep and began
my second animal farm
and they immediately started smashing
out kids my final idea was to
dye the adult sheet pink and look it
worked i now have pink wool on demand
i know this is tiny stuff for you guys
but for a noob like me
this was big brain territory day one one
five i made shears and used them i fed
the sheep to thank them
and then realized pink dyed sheep have
pink offspring
just like real life also a quick shout
out to the slender enderman for giving
me jump scares all week
the following morning i began to use
pink wool in my pagoda
this was pretty good but another big
brain moment i had was to use trapdoors
as windows they really do look legit
day 117 it actually looks like a pagoda
my enthusiasm grew on day 118 i returned
from a toilet break
and i was scared senseless the slender
enderman no longer wanted to be bros
i ran for my life and that night the
rack hives were back
and i have a feeling these guys have to
do with when i don't sleep enough
i'm not certain but i reckon that's how
it works the following day was spent
learning about wood and realizing which
woods would look better together
i realized i hardly ever looked at the
pagoda from the front
and on day 120 after a tough night in
the mines
i found this shot from my hobbit house
i'm happy with that
for a new builder with no reference
material that's pretty good
day 121 i was back in the mind
collecting obsidian for another portal
over at the pagoda
whilst mining i was almost burned alive
but luckily i'm starting to react a
little better
and survived maybe i actually could play
hardcore one day
the next morning i was given a jump
scare from my llama
i spent the rest of the day on the farm
this place is a mess
thanks to creepers explosions and that
slender enderman dude taking blocks
randomly
i'll fix it up one day but that's not
today because today
i gotta get meat if you're watching
vegan jeebus please forgive me
the next day was dedicated to clearing
the pagoda ready for the new portal
and when i built that portal i needed
more obsidian i actually stole a block
from the failed portal
and put it to good use we now have
portal 2. this one is definitely a
thicker than the original portal i did a
little bit of dumb science to see if the
corner of the portals were needed
and if size really doesn't matter also i
made a gate outside to prevent anything
that comes out of that portal from
escaping
i uh put pink wool on the sides because
i'm also very masculine
day 124 time to go into the nether again
i was worried and decided to bring
cobblestone with me and my mission the
moment i got there was to build a
protective hut
around the portal to keep it safe but
that went out of the window right away
because check this
my portal spawned 20 feet away from the
original portal
what are the chances and look a villager
is still alive
they are now living in the nether all my
unburnt items were here too
this honestly was an epic game of moment
but i realized i had a job to do i made
a protective wall
that donald trump would be proud of i
suddenly met an underworld dweller and
although i was scared
shizzleus he didn't attack so it seems
as long as i don't hurt them a truce
will be kept
the job now was to find a way to rescue
derrick yes i've named him derek he was
a step away from death
so i scooped up the lava and watched
derek frolic
in hell i also found nether quartz
whatever that
is it's a good day i came back the next
day to harvest those rocks on the roof
i have a crippling vertigo issue in
minecraft but knew if i kept crouched i
couldn't fall to my demise
and slowly went towards those glowing
cubes i forgot to crouch
and now yeah i'm still a noob but hey
i'm still alive
the next time i was way more careful and
made it to the new material
which like always i have no idea how to
use happy days
day 127 i decided to see if fast travel
was now an option for me
and i realized i could travel quickly
using the nether portals rather than
walking
16 seconds to get from my hobbit house
to the penny pagoda
this is a result the rest of the day i
messed around with nether materials
on day 128 i made a mistake while in the
nether i dared to look at the ender dude
boxing in this portal was the greatest
decision of my digital life
now day 129 i was looking through the
crafting books and noticed this
bad boy an enchanting table i felt this
was a good thing to own now my villagers
have mostly met their makers
so off i went to find all the pieces i
figured out paper and books easily
enough but diamonds were the bane of my
life
it took three days to find two diamonds
but hey
it's enough to make an enchanting table
it's day 132
here is my enchanting table i totally
love the animation by the way
so i decided to use it and no i don't
have a clue how to do that either
on day 133 i was on the farm again and i
have to admit
these ender dudes are the most annoying
things as they're always moving my
blocks
at some point we will need to attack
them the next day i made shelves around
my portal going for a harry potter sort
of theme in here
you're a wizard harry but in the end it
just looks like a widescreen tv
as day broke on day 135 i tried to
enchant a sword and realized
all that blue gold actually has a use
lapis lazuli
for the win yes i had issues i didn't
know how to actually
apply it anyway the next day i woke up
bright and early
and i was determined to figure it out
and look at this i'm a mother fudging
sorcerer
so many things click today i now
understand why those xp levels are
important
and the use of lapis lazuli and that was
probably the biggest day of learning
i've ever had
and i actually accidentally figured out
that more books around
this table equals higher levels so i
just need to figure out what on earth on
breaking means and the other ones
and then i might be getting somewhere
with this game i stayed in the mines on
day 137
it was boring so let's move on on day
138
we're back in the nether i decided to
see if i could change the profession of
derek i sure could he'll now sell me
books about vanishing
i've never needed vanishing in social
groups nobody never knows i'm
there in the fields i set up my
librarian with a bed and a storage unit
to make him feel a little more at home
when i arrived back in the real world
once again i caught the eye
of the ender dude moving my stuff around
again i decided today
this would be my stand and i looked him
in the eye
i found the perfect hiding spot from his
torment and systematically took him out
this is my home i will defend it after
teabagging him
i noticed he gave me an ender pearl
could this be something important
through the night of day 140 i decided
to fix
the holes around the farm it took
forever i need a ground keeper
as they broke on day 141 another
enderman decided to throw
down i took his pearl thing from his
lifeless digital corpse
day 142 and back to the pagoda today
was time to add a fence and bridge
across the moat
today i also saw a skeleton riding a
spider
minecraft is weird so weird
now day 143 i moved my llamas to act as
deterrent to portal invaders
i have no idea where the iron giant ran
off to the rest of the day was spent in
the mines gathering lapis
for badass sorcery enchantment the next
day i decided to look around the nether
a little more and chose to mine in a
straight line
i mined into lava let's pretend that
didn't happen okay
he needs some meal day 145 i was going
to sleep in the nether to make it my new
spawn point but the villager was already
in
full chillax mode i guess i did make
that bed for him
so i left it there on day 146 i began to
miss all my villagers and decided to go
out adventuring again
and find a new set to keep me from
getting lost i dropped torches on the
ground
like breadcrumbs to follow back home as
night fell the following day
i did it i found the new family my
favorites are dave and phil who like to
chill in the hot tub
24 hours a day i accidentally slept here
without realizing
and now i'm stuck here this is my spawn
point panic began to set in on day 148
i tried to change the settings to see if
i could spot my way home
i couldn't and became absolutely lost i
took a best guess and made a sky bridge
and prayed to all the gods including
odin and kratos
for days i continued never losing hope
until it happened
on day 151 we made it home
i found hut watch and penny's pagoda and
somehow
i now had a cat companion too i'm not
going to kill this one
i noticed how many people didn't like
that in the last episode i've learned my
lesson
so instead please name our feline
stalker but right now i had to figure
out
how to get down goldar saved me
right i made this cool time lapse of the
night of day 152 and the morning of day
153
i wish i remembered to put my gold pants
on now day 154
this cat is annoying me so much i know i
said i wouldn't off him so this guy
is going into a category instead but
once again just as i did something
constructive the marauders returned
up the snake eater ladder i went and
took them all out i wanted to see if a
raid would start
as all my villagers have already died no
raid started so now i know
raids are about villagers i legit pooped
my pantaloons when this guy came in my
front door
[Music]
in the early hours of day 155 i put up
another banner to show those marauders
what happens when they mess with me
we now have 15. i finished the category
just in time for the sunrise
and the damn cat got out little sh day
156
i changed my mind and put llamas in the
window pens
it took ages but i think it looks cool
i'm like the off-brand collector from
the guardians of the galaxy
on day 157 i decided to make enchantment
rooms to see if i could change the
sorcery on
offer making the bookcases was a pain in
the butt
as they can't be destroyed and replaced
anyway here's a start day 158
um i um pressed record at the wrong time
look mafia definitive edition
it's now day 159 i haven't been home for
a week or two so the last time i played
minecraft was a fortnight ago so like
usual my first day was spent on the farm
i changed my irrigation system today and
added a chest to collect the crops more
freely
before i could finish up though the
flying rats came back i managed to cool
one for illegally entering my property
um for some reason the audio hasn't
recorded on the next few days
so i will be making all the sounds in
minecraft with my own mouth
enjoy i finished the crops the next day
and also
took out a cheeky slenderman for another
pearl thing
with my leftover crops i fed the animals
in the slaughterhouse
greenhouse combination i accidentally
hit a few
totally accidental okay day 161 was a
day of science
i had the little marauder badge in the
top corner and i told myself
when i finished my wall i'd travel to
see the last villager nearby
to see if a raid would start it sure did
and like usual i was killed by an axe
wielding maniac
i decided to run back and get my own
loot even though night was approaching
i managed to grab everything except my
sword which is now
missing great tomorrow i will go back
for my arrows
and i sure did i realized how op
projectiles are in minecraft
i grabbed a couple of flags and came
back home 17 on the wall now
look at that i learned that i need to
improve tactically in battles
if i ever want to progress to hardcore
mode day 162.
today i decided to make a portal in the
village i found
three days away luckily my sky bridge
cuts down that journey and once i built
up to it
it was a simple run and only a few
moments later into my trek
look another village appeared it's
beautiful
even though it was night time i quickly
blocked in all the inhabitants and
rescued a villager stuck in a tree
then i slept this will be my home for
the next few days
i decided we needed a wall to protect
these guys so i began to fill cave
entrances
and chop down trees which the undead
tend to hide underneath
then this happened
i went boom and died from fall damage
oh well back to the wall it's day 164
i started making a glass smelting pot
there's not enough time to show you what
this is for in this episode you'll have
to wait for the next episode spam 300 in
the comments if you'd like to see this
noob series continue
day 165 and i began building a basic
wall around my villages
i can't tell you how anxious i am as
every person i've met so far
has gone deaded i wonder if i'm the
issue here
but now on my fourth attempt to be part
of a thriving community
i was getting things done by the end of
day 166
there was a wall sort of nice basic but
basic is safe
i made sure the wall was fortified the
next day but however i tried
zombie spawned inside my walls at
nightfall on day 168
i tried to link my three homes with
another portal i chose this church-like
place
but i didn't have enough obsidian so i
had to venture all the way back to the
pagoda to get another
upon arriving half my drawbridge was
destroyed
i'll get over it day 169
what else would you do on a day that
ends in 69 i smashed my weapon into the
face of an obsidian rock
good memories on day 170 i made my next
portal
it's like the eye of sauron but a
seriously budget version
i jumped into the portal in the hopes i
could see my previous ones
but no there's no chance of that sadly
this is a new location in the
netherlands
in the distance i noticed a new enemy
type to slay but i was way too scared
today maybe tomorrow
the next evening i encased sauron's
portal in glass
rip those villagers who died for me to
learn this lesson lest we forget
on day 172 i ventured back into the
nether
in order to find that new enemy i saw a
few days ago but strangely
i actually found my og portals instead
and spent the day making a bridge
between the two
for ease of travel i then hunted down
that new enemy and it died
immediately i was completely
underwhelmed so i made the decision to
update my game
and see if the new nether was better
than the old one now here it is the new
nether
oh baby jeebus is epic
the pig dudes still like me because we
both love gold i think
we even hunted together before loads of
them went swimming in lava
i chose not to join in and i think they
regret it
the problem in this new nether was my
portals they have vanished
i ran to the pagoda and somehow that
portal links to the same portal as the
one from the hobbit house
this is weird isn't it i decided to
break that portal and remake it in the
hopes of changing the spawn point
but then i realized i didn't have a
diamond pickaxe
day 175 i escaped the mine with more
diamonds
on the morning of 176 i made it back to
the pagoda
and broke and remade my portal it did
nothing it was a complete waste of a day
and then i was mercilessly pursued by
hogs
until i slowly died in lava this game
hates me
day 177 i hate the new nether
yesterday i accidentally hit a child in
the face and now
everything wants to kill me all the hogs
all the pigs
i ran for my life to make sure they
didn't get to motorize me
and i took my own life by the way i hate
the nether did i tell you that
on day 178 i stood in the rain all day
feeling sorry for myself that's the kind
of guy i am
on day 179 i ran home as fast as my
little legs could take me
i had a great idea hang on what's that
hissing noise
yep that happened anyway i totally got
home unscathed
the next day was spent in the mines
looking for gold because
gold is the best material oh i found
this i think
it's a spider spawner i blocked it up
and made a point to remember where it is
i forgot soon afterwards on day 181
i had an epic battle royale moment with
this set of skeletons
every man for themselves but of course
there could be only one champion
winner winner chicken dinner the morning
of day 182 was ruined by the enderman
peeping through my windows again
and leaving his rubbish on my window
ledge i've noticed that as the days go
on
the endermen are multiplying they must
be getting tips from
your mum i've been putting off going
into the nether for a while now but on
day 183
i swallowed my pride and ventured
forward there was a skeleton waiting for
me that was inconsequential
i built around my portal again to keep
things safe but realized
i hadn't been attacked by the pigs it
really is the gold that keeps them from
going
crazy i told you that gold was the
greatest material
all those months ago i learned how to
trade today with the pigs by throwing
gold at them that was fun
in return i got crying obsidian and soul
sand
i have no idea what that means but i'm
liking the nether again
the next day i was done with seeing red
everywhere and slowly cobblestoned the
floor
because the crimson was stressing me out
i ventured forward and found my second
portal i once again can fast travel to
my villages without traveling for an
in-game day
but it's a little more dangerous now
these hog things are here but it's still
worth it on day 185
operation villager began we all know
that i suck at keeping villagers alive
they all have committed sudoku over the
last 185 days
so i decided to play god and revitalize
the living
my plan was simple to force two
villagers into a cabin of love and then
lock them inside
until they bump uglies i tried throwing
food at them and stumbled
across bread is the food of love and
then i overfed them for a day
now day 186 and it finally happened
a beautiful moment between two fully
clothed villagers
we now have tiny people i threw in more
bread i want to build an army of dwarves
[Music]
the following day i made changes to the
baby-making cabin extending the lodge
adding beds and professions too
everything they could want without going
outside this was strangely satisfying
it's day 188 the house is upgrading well
babies are being made left right and
center and my nether runs are fruitful
but i still have no idea what i'm
looking for down here if i had to guess
i'm thinking it will be an ender dragon
that lives in a massive black
castle am i close at all also
what is this and why are they doing it
on day 189
i made a path between my two portal
homes and kept on adventuring into the
nether netherlands
i made roads to help me navigate the
vast underworld too they stopped me
getting lost
so many times the scary part though was
traveling over lava pits
i kept having flashbacks to day 76. we
don't talk about day 76
day 190 this noise happened
[Music]
i have no idea what i did but i'm
profoundly proud of myself
day 191 now and inside the nether i
found the scariest enemy ever
it spits pure fire
i made the decision to go home and grab
projectile weapons
this war is on oh hello and the dude
make yourself at home we're gonna need
arrows now but i didn't have enough
feathers
so it's time to make a chicken coop for
the next day and a half as night turned
into morning i was back at home base
trying to figure out a way to catch eggs
without having to be there all the time
i don't understand how hoppers work but
after a few minutes
it's pretty simple it essentially
catches items
and then delivers them into a container
underneath so i used it
to make a chicken prison complete with a
pink flower for comfort
now every time a chicken drops an edible
nugget i'll catch it
hey check this out on day 193 the pig
men had a dance-off
after a successful hunt i joined in but
i'm not one of the cool kids they they
all walked away anyway i have four
crossbows and every single arrow i could
muster
i was taking down casper the sadistic
ghost i marched across the bridge
feeling like a total badass
but devastation struck i was knocked off
and no matter how much i put off the
inevitable my tenth death had arrived
all of my items lost once again and then
i did it again straight afterwards why
does this game hate me so much
i took a real world day off because this
game was making me
so angry but anyway i came back on day
194
day 194 i'm back again i needed xp
levels to enchant my weapons and figured
out
that feeding animals on the farm gives
super fast xp
20 levels in about 60 seconds but right
away in the nether i was immediately
sick of walking around i still had no
idea what i was looking for down here
and the time to find something before
the episode ends
was starting to stress me out no end so
i went back to the sheep farm
i had a change of plan and it began with
a new structure
the following morning the erection began
i wanted something to look over the new
villages so they knew i would protect
them in their hour of need
i died so many sheep on this day and
needed their wool
i know it looks a bit not very good it
doesn't get much better i'll tell you
that now and i'm very sorry this is my
first attempt at a statue
on day 196 a creeper broke into my
baby-making cabin
it's okay i survived but the people they
escaped anyway here's the statue
yep still not my finest work i was using
an image i was sent on discord as
reference
and i don't think i did a good job of
following the blueprints anyway all that
scaffolding will be gone soon that's
simply there so i don't die when i jump
off the top of that erection
197 this build is so slow
it's the wall shortages i have to go
back to my farm to pick up crops which i
then feed to the sheep which then make
more babies who then i
scalp for their wool it's a long process
oh and look at that i actually finished
the build on day 198.
this is my ego statue adamaru the noob
i'm thinking about burning it down it's
98 wool so i'm guessing it would catch a
light
right in fact it's up to you shall we
keep this
i'll burn it down at the start of the
next episode i'll be in the comments to
see what you decide
so it's day 199 my penultimate day of
the episode
i uh bit the bullet and went back into
the nether
could i find something monumental before
the end came
it was tricky business so i used all my
last diamonds to craft brand new gear
and then after running away from a
spitting casper it happened
i stumbled across a huge fortress-like
castle
it was legit a little bit scary looking
around and then i saw this thing
i panicked and raced back into the
corridors but this time i came prepared
i built a new portal an easy way to get
back to this place
right away the next day when things were
safer
but there was something i didn't take
into account
it's now my final day the night is
becoming dawn
day 200 the portal worked beautifully
but now now i'm stuck in this new area
all alone my choice is to either commit
sudoku and respawn back at home
forever risking never finding that black
castle again in the nether
or i make this place my new home
and start new with the next episode i'll
leave that decision for you
what do we do next in this new
playthrough
if you've made it this far please take
my thank you i really appreciate it i
know
this can't be fun watching an idiot play
a game like minecraft for so long
if you would like another episode please
hit me with the word 300 in the comments
below and i'll do my best to start
episode 3 instead of waiting
4 months next time sorry about that i do
enjoy making this series but it takes a
long long
time i'm happy to keep going i'm happy
to keep going
i'm adam it's been a pleasure thanks for
your time i'll see you in another